so this is nothing more than the same
way for Ghent so instead of like trying
to push him we project through his arm
his mass is offering some kind of young
energy and that allows me to push okay
which is why if he takes away his
structure right and I go to do that same
thing there's no effect on his posture
which is why as he goes to do that right
you have to find find his Center so
these are all skilled problems we've
been working right okay so what we want
to understand now is yin and Yan or
relative there is no Yin innately do you
got that there's no Indian so when he
comes in if I offer more young energy
then he is he's actually getting I knew
that you can y'all so the way that I do
that is I will release me more I release
more okay so let's say he's barely
pushing I just have to release even more
than
he is see every time every time and then
you can DC and still find that the mass
enough to manipulate response okay so as
he goes to push I I don't do it
externally I do it internally release
and now his young not just in terms of
his physique but his young projecting
energy is now manipulable whining okay
so as I go here I'm now not aiming his
body but aiming that that force line so
as opposed to I'm going to take his hand
at random so I immediately go yet and I
have
emotionally I'm not turning this wrist
this wrist may turn his had made lower
but I'm not doing that okay so for
example here's one where I pushing his
hand and it might look to you like my
hand was connected but what I'm telling
you is I'm not pushing his arm
I am redirecting his force and just
allowing connected to see that same
thing when I do if his wrists burns it's
not that I'm turning his wrist his wrist
is just the energies going that way
right and I'm just staying connected
[Music]
when you feel the mass the beginner
tendency is to now push okay but if you
push if you push on it right now you're
not into him and now he's not gone to
you and you can't push you not push you
back on him
you don't push you back on that energy
so once you feel his gin dope start like
yeah stay